what do Magnus Carlson and hakaru
Nakamura have in common they both
recently lost to Wesley so in the
Champions chess tour finals Wesley and
world number one Magnus Carlson had
perfect scores going into their match
their first game was dead even
throughout ending in a cheeky stalemate
draw after the second game ended in a 17
move draw it was clear both players had
an appetite for Armageddon magnus's sub
n minute bid gave him the black pieces
and draw odds Wesley pulled out a bold
sacrifice early in the game on the 13th
move reminiscent of Romantic Era chess
Wesley took us back to the Romantic Era
while not a sound sacrifice on paper
Wesley expertly navigated the
complicated position that ensued
eventually ending up with the queen
against a rook and Bishop Magnus had a
subtle M and one threat but Wesley was
too sharp for that and Magnus eventually
resigned then after another Armageddon
win this time against Notre Beck Abdu
satarov Wesley took the sole lead with a
6 and0 record in the tournament can
anyone defeat Wesley so in Toronto